Welcome everybody to another Zoom call where we're just going to do our best to answer questions that you might have
And a double message that came in today, so
We'll jump right at it remember to look for any updates and
cancel the Zoom call for some reason or something like that
really do an updated
Any major changes which we haven't had any major changes in the clinic for quite some time
But they'll be listed in the at the instance page
Also remember you can self-schedule on our website or on your member page
Okay, first question. What are your thoughts on high dose hyperbectom?
Dr.
Baptist Canadian and D wrote
2017 Mexican study showed a work better than chemo for breast cancer. He also gives guidelines at dosage for various cancers
I'm a big pan of hyperbectom and bedband is all for cancer. I understand though both bedband is all and hyperbectom would be considered a
parasitic as far as
How it works and why would we prescribe?
They function completely different as far as some cancer goes and
hyperbectom and bedband is all would be two different protocols
They're not some people think that the hyperbectom works and bedband is all works because cancer is
From a parasite or from a fungus or from a
virus that's not the mechanism of action, so it's not because it's killing
parasite
It's testing a parasite. It's all works on cancer totally
Can't have action with cancer
We have a number. You see the hyperbectom protocol. I know there is guidelines
You can google the guidelines on how to use it
It general the guideline for use of hyperbectom for virus or
infection
Like COVID was 12 milligrams a day for an average weight of a hundred feet or something like that
But it's based upon kilogram weight so the average dose is about 12 milligrams a day for COVID
But for cancer, it's about five times that much. So you want to find a source that
You're not paying you
Yeah, they had a doses of one milligram per kilogram. So it was like for I weigh 81
So it would be 80 gram milligrams. Don't such a daily. Yeah. Yeah, that's all right
So I would say to I know that there if you could find a prescribing
Doctor who will give you a prescription for it that you could get at a compound date
Pharmacy and get a compounded for you. That's probably the cheapest way to go
Okay, I know there's other sources that you could buy it like
You know
It's not the black market, but outside of getting a prescription, you know, because it's such a hot item for
You know a possible next pandemic that might be launched on us
But I think those sources are typically much more expensive
So if you can't get it and then it's a lot easier to take than taking you know
six or 12 milligrams
Catholics, you know, so we get it in one
Council that don't such a good way to take
The only thing that I would say you have to be careful about and this is totally based upon experience
With i-revected end-fin bed is all you want to keep an eye on your
your
liver markers
because
It can raise your alkaline costs ASD and ALT
um
Because it can it can be hard on your liver
Now that's not every month, but um, I've had some people where I had to have the pulse kit
Where they go off it for a month and then their
Help those liver markers would come back down and they'd go back under the months
And keep you know running a complete metabolic panel
Um, just see if those start to rise up again, then they go off and go again
So you might have the pulse of just keep an eye on that
That's the only thing that I would recommend
There really isn't any other side effects
I've had a couple people with but men is all have say they have stomach gags with it
But let's just took a spoon and that went away
The only thing is that liver issue because anybody can never pay to the inflammation in the liver
That
Can damage your liver see it's got to keep an eye on that
I just had cheek swab um protocol update and some questions pectosol C
One scoop a day increased to three scoops a day. Can this be done all at once in a slowly um, yes, you can
Um, it doesn't mix very well any other way
The pectosol C will dissolve instantly in orange juice for citrus juice though
Um, so if you just need to take a couple
ounces of course, that's sugar. I don't know. It's not necessarily good for you
But take a couple ounces of orange juice you put it in there literally dissolves like
Magic and you could drink it down that way too, but
Otherwise, everybody else puts it as smoothie
Dan Delay liquid take three tablespoons a day. It's split doses
Does this mean?
One tablespoon three different times a day. Yeah, so
Would whatever I say split doses that means try to split it up as best as you can
But technically a split dose of its three tables would today be one table spoon three times a day
but
But really when I mean split doses, it's just try to get it split up
You take one and a half and then I could only do it morning and evening
I work full-time. There's no way I could do it at work
Or I forget my new and time then just split it up into two. You wanted to have a table spoon
This section I read this greens first replaced with young jeopardy continue. That's my mistake
That should not say continue
so
Sorry about that
On the young jeopardy power did not powder to not test well for you. Don't greens first powder test well for you. So
um
No, most people use these for uh
For a
Multiple vitamin to get all nutrition in
But when it doesn't test for somebody that it's like okay, what do you use?
Well, again, I'm not saying that
Everybody needs to be out of multiple either if you're eating well and you're getting enough calories today. You're probably eating
Your your main nutrition. So um
Then you're just going to start looking at like specifically
um is there uh like
I'm like deficient in minerals in the summer um and I
Out my deficient in B vitamins. I mean start looking at things like that
Um, I can give you. I will
um
Uh
Come up with a suggestion. I'll email you a suggestion for a multi vitamin mineral
Um struggle is is that most of the multi vitamins out there
have things like copper in them or they have um
Uh
Enter oxidants in them. So I will look and find one for you
It's not very often that a person tests negative for these things but you did for some reason
I don't know so I'll find a good one for you but I'll be right
I had colorectal resection surgery June 17th and cathology report indicated that it was complete
being that all visible cancer was removed with safe margins
However, I don't have the highest CEA readings
ever at 18
Uh nanograms per milliliter also by circadian
uh
DNA tumor cell
sanitary tests for uh
but
was first test was
ever was 24 uh
And I read that CEA is often high
for one to five months
I think post surgery you read and settles down
but may not be the case if sanitary test is also high
why do high scores uh seem to happen for many people post surgery
I had a lonely question but please speculate
somebody else asked this question uh
uh two weeks ago to to to workers elevate post surgery
and
I don't know I did it I didn't quite as I didn't search for any research on that
um
And I don't know that there actually would be research on that
maybe some bold research at the tumor markers came out
first came out what it deduced
two dozen years ago but um they're just used less and less now um
because of things like this you know I've stated that
but my belief is that i'm college is told
there's two workers because they assume that you're going to do
chemotherapy and many times when you do chemotherapy
or two workers in a go time so um
whoever two markers are uh an enzyme that are released by different cells not just
cancer cells so um in the uh in the um
active surgery you're going to be damaging cells and
two markers can go up I don't know how long they will stand
I'm not sure about that um if if you debunk to so just think about it if you
debunk the cancer and you're removed all the visible cancer
and let's say you do a PET scan and there's nothing else hot
spot in your body so they think that you're
there's quote unquote no evidence of disease we all know that you still have
cancer different places we all do even if you've never been diagnosed
but it's definitely under you know a couple of
million cells large but that even that it can still um
you know we give it up two of our first um enzymes and show positive two of
our certainly show you don't have some two of our first
but that certainly uh if if that was true if if we just make those assumptions
that everybody does have some other cancers in their body
outside of the primary site surgery on the primary site is not gonna
make the other sites more active so from just a
physiological understanding search let's say you have colon cancer and you
move that part of the colon you debunked it
very clean margins it is certainly not gonna make
let's say even if you do you had metastasis that in itself is not gonna make
the metastasis go crazy the only danger in surgery
is that you know your body has to heal from the surgery and a
healing for the surgery your body makes and it gives off
more growth hormone and growth um stimulating cells to heal from
the wound um could that be uh the fuel too or you know adding
gasoline on the fire of uh metastatic tumor yes
that could that could be but you're taking out the bulk of the tumor
which you'd have to say if you had elevated tumor markers prior to
surgery the majority of it had to be coming from that mass
and removal of it um what should you think would then
lower the C.V.A. of readings um yeah but prior prior to surgery it was like
four or five in G's per whatever milliliter and never never was very high at all
and I met with oncologists two days ago and he said
basically you have an active cancer going on there so
they're not even gonna do a hip replacement undergoes circumstances which is
another question I asked for. I was sorry to interrupt.
yeah so your latest PET scan showed what again?
I did I've never had a PET scan the last MRI showed you know just basically the tumor
trunk from like eight centimeters to 2.1 and that's what they removed
shortly thereafter so I haven't had a scan since the operation
was there eighty side of the testicist anywhere?
nope they did uh they purposely did a chest
MRI of the whole torso and stuff and they didn't find anything
okay then and and the surgeon looked around also when she was in there
and she didn't observe anything uh either
then I would just wait and out I wouldn't be concerned about those numbers and
tell your body settles down remember any lab you do
is a clue um but things can change because of other
reasons too you have surgery so that could throw off different markers um
and there's not a lot of data on how surgery throws on
tumor markers so we just don't know I mean just I just know
in um if my practice that is a common thing when a person has surgery they're
tumor markers spike and go up and can be up there
up for several months um it makes me think that
that's just and again like I said before another reason why
the colleges have shined away from doing tumor
for testing because they have to sit there and sit down with a person and
explain what I've explained to you well it can go up
after this and the person's freaking out that their cancer is
spread and I thought you just got an all blah blah blah so
it's easier not to do the test if it's going to give
you false positives um so if the test is for
it shows elevation showing and that equates to increase
cancer growth um that elevation post surgery that
doesn't equal increase cancer risk would be a false
positive so um I would I would wait it out
let your body flush that out and the only concern I
have is that the signatory CT DNA is triggered off
of the actual DNA from whatever they biopsyder took
out during from the pathology after surgery
and that supposedly has a very short half life so
if you find some of that maybe that indicates that
something's out there in your body somewhere
so that's the one that scares me a little more
be honest and it and I think the if if you're concerned about
I think the next test would be a password okay thank you
what are the signs and symptoms of leaky gut
but leaky gut can cause all sorts of problems elsewhere
in your body so the signs and symptoms can vary greatly
depending on how bad leaky gut is the leaky
leaky gut is where you have um particles of food
that you've got anything that's in the in the gut
passing into the bloodstream because um um
damaged to the gut wall so when you have damaged to the gut wall
you could have um uh take us get across the gut wall that should never get
across the gut wall so perfect example would be
proteins um I think if a protein is a lung
chain of amino acids they're supposed to break down
through enzyme activity in the gut
through very small chains of amino acids and then to
single amino acids or a pair of amino acids called a
dipeptide and that's the largest thing
as far as protein consumption that should cross the gut wall
as a dipeptide two amino acids connected together
mostly single amino acids across the gut wall
and when you have damaged to the gut wall or damaged
to um the cells themselves you could get things
crossing the gut wall that should never cross the gut wall
the problem with that is that your immune system can react to those things
and when your immune system reacts to those things you can develop antibodies
against those things and every time you eat that
same food you know you have antibodies in your bloodstream
and antibodies in the lumen of the gut that will
fire interview reaction against that peptide
and when you do so not causes a greater amount of
inflammation and even greater amount of damage to the
gut wall so it looks uh cascade effect of a negative loop
so uh symptoms can be buried from
tummy aches to systemic inflammation to
rashes to um brain inflammation to um it's just the list goes on and on and on
because when you have inflammatory response it's because of foods that you
eat then you know every time you eat that food you're
going to have this inflammatory response and
you know you have different gluteal morphine in case you're morphine
receptors in the gut and in the brain you're going to cause inflammation
of the brain and it looks quite completely okay
also it's a yes and step so you test for that
so you can test you can test for that through what's called
syrex array two tests syrex array two tests for
both counts of leaky gut syndrome you forget paracelular
transmission paracelular damage we need
that's the most commonly described form of leaky gut where
you have uh things getting between the cells the damage cells
are causing a gap between the cells and therefore things are getting
between the cells or you could have transcellular
conduction of material because the cells themselves are so
damaged that's a worst form of leaky gut and then later the
final damage of leaky gut is when you end up developing antibodies
to life and polysaccharides which then will damage
life and polysaccharide antibodies when you do direct damage to the blood
right there so it gets more complicated
and gets more serious so leaky gut isn't something
so just pretend it doesn't happen that it becomes a
dealing with it so testing for it can be valuable
a test of what it is positive maybe you have to test for
different foods and go down the line to to try to clean that up
so it's a common scenario for most diseases
could start in that that's what people with functional doctors say
every disease starts to the gut well that's not true
a lot of diseases start in the gut this is what's talking about
because you have this chronic inflammation and you get things that
pass the gut wall that should never pass the gut wall even toxins that
should never pass the gut wall and then um
dig into the body they can damage the body they get into the cells they can
damage the nucleus they can be a cause of cancer so
hopefully that answers that recently when doing a coffee animal by
stomach feels bloated and upset afterward is it possible that fluid and
waste are being pushed back up into the stomach and if so
this seems terrible toxic and what can I do about it if not
what might be happening well definitely doing a coffee
animal is not going to push fluid and waste back up it's your
stomach that's absolutely not happening physiology
unless you had 85% of your your the testinal tract
remove you have 30 feet of a testinal tract and by you
even doing a quart of coffee into your colon you're not really
backing up much and thus you're holding it for
five hours and you continue to put more coffee up there and nothing ever comes
out so that's that physiologically possible
if you feel bloated and upset after a coffee
animal it could more likely be a blockage
your bio doctor gallbladder putting a hot pack
kesteral packs over your liver gallbladder would be the right thing to do
so if whole purpose of coffee animal is through the repair of synthetic nervous
systems stimulating slow phase one phase two pathways in your liver
but if you have a blocked gallbladder give a lot of gall stills or something
like that there's going to be blockage there and you could be
unbloded and stuff because of that other possible reason
doing having if it's happening constantly after doing a coffee
animal could be a sensitivity to the caffeine
people can have caffeine sensitivity and you've got a switch to maybe a
cannabino cannabino or something like that just to happen once or twice
then you'd think either way it could be a gallbladder issue too soon
look at that
bye doctor C just had an ultrasound of my three months check up after
bead uh move front and box spin the lumps and shrunken by
30% so far so good my labs showed a few results that need
improvement however I sent those labs to you
um sorry I've done looked at those yeah what can I do it in
praise these numbers a collegeist will review labs
at the end September 23rd and will advise the next steps hopefully
continuation of status quo is it okay for me to start back but all
my steps after a four-month break has a protocol
um I honestly I think I would do another cheap swap test before you start
back on everything um short of that I mean certainly you
could start back on things and maybe you start with a lower
gulce and tight trade off but maybe do it on a cheap swap
test in the middle and if you want me to go over those labs with you
speak in a planet I did not know that your labs so I'm sorry
okay is the right program stomach flu a good thing to run if you think
the stomach is upset upset isn't a virus um yeah yeah there's multiple flu
programs there's cold and flu on coming in there's oh gosh there's
half a dozen flu programs at least um there's the viral complex
program um which goes through multiple different viruses um
so and people are gonna respond differently to different to different
frequencies so we're just gonna have to try to different
programs and see which one you know works the best for you
historically I've heard the best comments from the viral complex program
in the cold and flu on coming program um so but I certainly give those a try
too but yeah whatever you know you should be using your
life for cold morbidity some or just other issues that you have going on
should be running different programs um as you as you see fit to do so
you have other things but other people have if your family have other things
going on make sure you go to your life as your first
light of defense against and just to go to everything so
um I know people get used to running my program all the time
you know I turn on my ice every night you're on my program
but if I feel like I have something with going on on a different program I work
oh all right what I was talking to Dr. Chi last week he said not to take vitamin E
with cancer as that can allow the cancer to cross the brain
have you ever heard of that he also said not to take
niacin with cancer I don't remember the reason
that you mentioned the vitamins before any kind of that
um well I would disagree with him on the vitamin E
um higher dose vitamin E because what's in the ACOME that we used
has been shown with multiple studies to be
beneficial for all kinds of cancer and in fact I think I cite multiple studies
on breast cancer and vitamin E higher dose vitamin E like that is oxidative
and it's um it's been shown in multiple times to be
cancer preventative and cancer killer showing and disagree with that um
niacin with cancer so I think the thought process is taking
high dose niacin can dilate your blood vessels um
thereby the thought process I'm thinking maybe I'm completely wrong
it's what he's thinking would be if you die if you're dilating your blood
vessels then you're then you're um you're you're getting more
um fuel source to the cancer but uh I just would disagree with that as well
um if you're dilating your blood vessels then you're also
you know getting the um your immune system to your cancer better your
oxygenated your cancer better which is going to kill the cancer
oh yeah so I don't agree with that when I've said about the B vitamins is
methylated B vitamins um because methyl groups will turn off
genes that we will silence tumor suppressor genes so in every cell including
cancer cells you have a genetic um through
meditative that is supposed to be turned on to kill the cancer which
stimulates the intrinsic apoptotic pathway so um and that is the
tumor suppressor system so god given tumor suppressor system turns on
when uh when a cell becomes cancerous quote-unquote when you're
nucleus is damaged it starts reproducing this happens literally
probably on a daily basis in all of us your tumor suppressor system then kicks
out and the cells go through uh
the intrinsic pathway of apoptosis killing the cell
um that's why we don't all have a diagnosis of cancer so um
methylated you know excess methyl groups will silence those genes
could turn those genes off and I don't think we should do that when you have
cancer you only you have to look at other factors
two plus it's homocysteel is really fine and you've got to take that
for care so you gotta do all of that. I'm trying to
increase my MMS dosage to get up to the cancer protocol
of key perks seed that have to back off progress is slow is the
herks are actually a good side and the MMS is
finding stuff to kill well um probably ask you the wrong person because
I'm not a big fan of the MMS protocol for cancer
um and the reason is is that MMS is going to be
more physiologically a killer of um living organisms
like bacteria or fungus or something like that
that it is going to be a cancer it's not going to be
attracted to cancer cells for say um
and uh you've got to define whether you're really happy
in a herks reaction or you're having a toxicity
reaction from the MMS because MMS is a toxin
so I don't I don't know I mean if you really feel like you should be doing
the MMS protocol then by all means continue to do it
um lots of times when people have product line they're doing
the MMS and um those same people with product line
will be making a comment like this if they're getting a
herks reaction it's not always whatever you feel
lousy after taking something it's not always a herks reaction
sometimes uh it's a toxicity reaction from the thing you're taking
sometimes it's stimulated on a mutory action
MMS wouldn't do that but a lot of people with line
could play it after doing a like a cat's plot till the
college something like that of their herks seed and they just got to keep
fighting through it they'll probably not herks see
you're probably stimulated on a mutory action you're having
cell death that that which we have antibodies against
so it's not really a herks reaction at all
I just don't know in your case if it is or not
um I would make sure you're getting blood work done
and make sure we're looking at
um at um your
um liver markers if those are all clean and your
alkaline positive is normal stlt is normal
maybe it's a herks reaction um
uh just i don't i just i don't i don't i don't know that i have
tested anybody in the last 10 years with cancer that tested positive for
MLS so i'm not a good person to ask about that
so from an ultrasound i filed an 8 millimeter kidney
stone so i've been drinking lemon juice with olive oil
apple cider vinegar a couple times a day
and uh for a couple weeks could this be affecting my
gall letter and somehow contributing to the stomach
well after it ends up um yes it could um
um i don't yeah i don't know about lemon juice and olive oil
for kidney stone um
and definitely the lemon juice and olive oil
is going to affect your gallbladder so anytime you eat
a lot of fat it's going to affect your gallbladder it's going to be
contracting apple cider vinegar no that will affect your
gallbladder negatively at all um don't know how that's
going to help kidney stone either there is an herb
for kidney stones i can't remember the name of it
herb farm sells it in a liquid dropper called
stone breaker that has been helpful for a lot of
people who i want to check here today as well
i used to put 35% food grade 100 proxide in water
i built up extremely slowly to 14 to 10 12 to 14 drops daily and 12
ounce in the water once a day on an empty stomach
many people discourage this but is there value in this
so i did your proxide is an oxidizing agent
so either proxide can be great if you can get it to the
cancer so in your case asking this question with
colon cancer you have a lot better chance
taking it orally getting it to the cancer
than you do if you'll find a cancer in the liver or in the lungs or in the
breast or in the brain because hydrogen proxide is not
going to stay as hydrogen proxide and absorb
into your blood serenose hydroproxide it's going to change
and protect um benefit probably the best use of hydrogen
proxide orally to be for like a stomach cancer
you'd probably be much better option to try to get
hydroproxide directly to the cancer with colon cancer
in your end of it
so again you know when you take something orally
that can kill cancer directly
you're you're you're you have to go i have to
to the cancer orally to the cancer
is it going to change physiologically in the stomach
you know is it going to be absorbed is it going to break down
the answer is yes i really don't think the proxide
take it away it's going to get to your colon
it's going to get to the stomach so you don't have to do it as it can
but um that's where like people will take um
they keep so that they alkalize their body well really you're only alkalizing
your stomach and i want to alkalize the cancer
okay well unless you had stomach cancer you know
it's not going to really help maybe you stop a
geo and certainly maybe um you know do i
go cancer but beyond that it's going to be
broken down having blood work next week
what should i add to the order to make sure
it doesn't cause any problems make sure you do a
complete metabolic panel complete metabolic panel
that will show those liver monitors
beta FYI herb farm is spelled buddy yes
ph-a-r-l yes
uh i use the cell still breaker all the time we worked at health
with students um sorry about the audio
thank you christia used uh yeah
show uh t-a-dra still breaker yes very good
all right will be another question for today
all right well thank you guys for being on today
um we'll see you all that week we'll be praying for you
hope you have come with this summer here
bye bye